good evening and congratulations to this
year's incredible group of filmmakers
you should be especially proud of your
accomplishment because this year's
student academy award was another record
setter we received 1749 entries from
student filmmakers attending 381 schools
around the world making 2016 the most
competitive year ever nice job everyone
we have added two new categories this
year as well in addition to the foreign
narrative category we now have the
foreign animation and foreign
documentary categories as new categories
this year we'll award one gold medal to
each for us-based students before
categories our animation documentary
narrative and alternative each of which
may be awarded up to three medals as
Cheryl mentioned we had more academy
members than ever participating in the
judging process so I too would like to
extend a personal thank you to all the
Academy members who participated your
involvement was indispensable especially
with the record number of entries thank
you thank
thank you for your commitment to
supporting this next generation of
filmmakers now to begin tonight's
program with the documentary and foreign
documentary categories I would like to
introduce our first awards presenter
Daisy Ridley created the instantly
iconic character of Ray and 2015's star
wars the force awakens and will reprise
the role in the next installment of the
Star Wars saga due out in 2017 in
October the Eagle Huntress a documentary
she executive produced will be released
please welcome Daisy Ridley